- [Justin] So, I wanna
start by asking a question.
Who here, whose title
like, or job description
officially like has the
word FinOps in it somewhere?
How many hands?
Raise your hands.
You got like four or five.
Okay, maybe like 10.
Probably about what a
quarter of the room or so.
Who's in the second group where your title
has absolutely nothing to do with FinOps
and you've kind of accidentally stumbled
into having to do cost
allocation or cost reporting?
Yeah, my hand's up for this one.
Awesome.
(Jason chuckles)
So I'm Justin Marks, I'm a
senior technical account manager
with AWS Support.
Jason.
- [Jason] So this is
Jason, product manager
for AWS Cost and Usage Report and FOCUS.
- [Justin] Cool.
And we're gonna talk to you today about
advanced multi-cloud cost
reporting with FOCUS.
But before we get into the FOCUS topic,
I want to take everybody
back through probably
a common scenario you've
dealt with over your career
of dealing with cost and
usage data in the cloud.
So you had a team who started using AWS
and you had to figure out
four things about cost
and usage data, how you're
gonna collect that data, right?
Getting the reports turned on,
where you're gonna deliver them.
And then you're gonna have to figure out
how to normalize it, get it into formats
that the finance team cares about,
get it into formats that
your engineering teams
or the teams that wanna visualize
like how to get it into those formats.
You're gonna need to figure
out how to analyze it.
What tools are you gonna use?
Are you gonna go pick one off the shelf?
Are you gonna try to
wing it with, you know,
some of the native tooling depending on
which cloud provider you're with?
And then how are you gonna
derive insights out of that data?
And finally how to visualize it, right?
Ultimately folks end
up building dashboards
and trying to find ways to build reports
for their executives on how this is going.
And it stops there, right? (chuckles)
It wouldn't be a multi-cloud conversation
if it didn't stop there.
So then you get another
team who comes and says,
Hey, we use this SaaS platform
and this SaaS platform
has costs and usage and we
need the data from there too
and we'd like to integrate
that in our reporting pipeline.
So you have to go figure
out these four things
for that provider too.
And then when you know it,
you hear about this other team
that's running in another cloud
and now you gotta go figure out again.
And you can see where I'm
going with this, right?
So having to relearn
these things every time
you adopt a new provider,
you use a new SaaS
platform, it could be hard.
And, Jason, what do we have to help folks
manage this complexity?
- [Jason] Sure. So the
thing of practitioners
spend countless hours every
day to normalize the data.
And this is because
different providers out there
define the data differently
and we wanna solve that problem
for our customers and we
wanna solve it at the root.
So organized by the FinOps Foundation
under the antitrust
compliance that we work
with different FinOp practitioners
from different industries
and created this new open
specification called FOCUS.
So FOCUS stands for FinOps Open Cost
and Usage Specification.
It provides consistent cost and usage data
such as building,
pricing and cost metrics.
So, lemme take you
through a quick journey,
how the FOCUS journey would look like
when you start with the FOCUS.
So when you start FOCUS,
you will first get the data
from your data generators.
This can be your cloud providers,
it can be your SaaS providers
or even your data center providers.
So FOCUS is a open
specification anyone can create.
And as of today the majority
of the large cloud providers
has adopted FOCUS and we
are seeing increasing trend
for the SaaS providers to adopt FOCUS.
This will give you a universal
view of your cloud cost
and use data across all
your technology stack,
not just limiting to cloud.
So once you get your
data from your providers,
you inject that data to
your FinOps tool platforms,
this can be Amazon Athena,
which we will be demoing today
and for to query the data directly.
And you can also visualize your FOCUS data
using the Amazon QuickSight
or even plug those data
into Excel for different insights.
And once you have the data injected
to your FinOps data platforms,
you can analyze the data
for different use cases
such as demonstrating
your business values, finding
optimization opportunities
across the vendors that you have with.
So now you understand how the
FOCUS look like in high level.
So let's us do a quick exercise.
Justin, can you help us to
run a quick exercise to see
where people are with the FOCUS journey?
- [Justin] Yeah, we're just
trying to see where folks are.
I think I may have asked
a couple of you outside
so I have a little bit of a
sample to base this off of,
but hands up if you've
seen the FOCUS spec,
like you've read some of
the documentation out there?
It's about half the room.
Okay, so for the folks
with their hands down,
you've now seen part of the FOCUS spec.
It's a big document.
It covers things like
normative requirements,
different columns, things about metadata
and attributes for the
cost of usage data set.
This is an example of
availability zone, right?
You get a nice definition here.
It explains the intention,
it calls out you might,
and the bullet points here,
the first bullet point says
it is recommended column, right?
So it's not mandatory, it
may or may not be populated.
That'll be important later.
It's type string, things like that, right?
So we can scratch this one off.
Everybody in this room has
seen part of the FOCUS spec.
So let's do hands up if you
have FOCUS reports like created
and you're playing around
with that data today?
A couple hands up.
It's about half the room. Okay.
How about if you have analyzed
or visualized this FOCUS data before?
So, it's not just there.
You're actually like using it,
your teams are looking at it.
Hands up if you've?
Okay.
And how about if you've
joined AWS FOCUS data
with other providers?
A quick show of hands who's
pulled in multiple providers?
- [Jason] Including the SaaS providers,
- [Justin] Including SaaS and other.
Okay, we got four or five hands.
Okay, great.
So I mean it's a pretty
good understanding of,
we have a good understanding now
of the experience with FOCUS in the room.
So, Jason, do you want
to talk to us about how,
for the folks that had their hands down
who haven't created the reports yet,
how they can create FOCUS for AWS?
- [Jason] Sure.
So AWS data exports platform
is the centralized data
hub for you to export all
your FinOps related data set.
As of today we support
four different table types.
The first one is AWS
Cost and Usage Report 2.0
which is our native
supported cost and usage data
and it provides the most
granular AWS cost and usage data.
And the second is the FOCUS.
We currently supporting 1.0 and 1.2
that we just launched two weeks ago.
And third is the cost
optimization recommendations,
which pulls the data from
cost optimization hub
to help you to identify the
cost optimization opportunities
like right sizing or savings
plan recommendations.
And lastly is the carbon
emissions exports,
which provides you the
carbon footprint data
associated with your
database usage to help you
to better track your sustainability data.
So let's dive a little bit deeper
to the FOCUS data set with AWS Columns.
So we launched FOCUS 1.0 last
year during the re:Invent
and FOCUS 1.0 includes
the 48 columns total.
43 columns from the FOCUS 1.0 spec itself
and we added five additional AWS columns.
This would help the
customers to better navigate
the AWS resources with FOCUS itself.
And there are eight columns
with conformance gaps
and we have published those
in the conformance gap report
and we also did that in the 1.2.
So as mentioned FOCUS 1.2
we have just launched two weeks ago.
Definitely encourage to have a try
for this enhanced version
of a FOCUS specification.
So FOCUS 1.2 provides 14
new additional columns
on top of FOCUS 1.0.
It includes capabilities
like capacity reservation ID
and status columns help
you to better manage
your capacity reservations,
will break down
your capacity reservation
use and unused status.
It's included the invoice ID column
which help you to better
reconcile your cost
and usage data with the physical invoices.
It also includes the capabilities
with for SaaS providers
to generate the FOCUS data set
due to the newly increased,
newly introduced the
pricing current columns.
So enable SaaS providers
to integrate their pricing
in the terms of tokens
and virtual currencies.
And it also added more grand
narrative for SKU usage
and for SKU usage and analysis.
This includes your usage type
and also product attributes.
And last one is the account
structure classification.
It help you to identify whether your usage
is coming from your management account
or from the member account.
And one more thing I'll
highlight here is FOCUS 1.2
also start supporting hourly, daily
and monthly time
granularity which FOCUS 1.0
today we are only supporting our data.
Okay, Justin, you gave a
great presentation last year
about CUR 2.0 and this year you are given
a presentation about FOCUS.
What are the difference?
- [Justin] Yeah, so who here
feels, we had half the room
have like played around
with FOCUS or turned it on?
How many folks feel
comfortable with like cost
and usage reports CUR, have
like played around in CUR?
Alright, a couple more.
So, I think it's valuable
to just take a minute here
and frame up some of the relations
and stuff between the two data sets.
One of the most common
questions I've got about FOCUS
up to this point is like do these columns
map to each other, right?
And how do we map CUR 2.0
values to FOCUS values?
So here's a quick example,
a non-exhaustive list.
This is eight columns that I
picked out that map one-to-one.
So this is things like your,
you know, account information,
the charge periods, things
like the service names,
resource IDs and tags, right?
So if you look at usage
rows and in CUR 2.0,
they map directly the values
that you would see in FOCUS 1.0.
There are also columns like blended cost
and line item type that are related,
but the values aren't
gonna map one to one.
Sometimes things will map and sometimes
there are requirements in
FOCUS 1.0 for specific values
that you're not gonna see in CUR.
So, they're related.
One informs the other,
the CUR 2.0 values inform
what you see in FOCUS, but
they're not gonna map one to one.
There's also some net new columns
that you get from adopting FOCUS.
These are things like effective cost.
Who here is a fan of
using net amortized view
in Cost Explorer?
Hands up if you've used
net amortized view.
If you wished that was in in CUR.
We don't have a column in there today,
but there are ways, I'll
show you in a few minutes
how to get this value out of
the cost and usage reports.
But effective cost is essentially
the net amortized cost
from Cost Explorer.
So if you adopt FOCUS, you can
expect those values to align.
We also have things like service category.
So if you were using CUR to analyze
all of your storage usage, let's say,
or all of your compute usage,
you would have to build
a big where statement, add
all the services, usage types,
et cetera, that would, that you'd need
to track there and report on.
But you can use service category in FOCUS
and it's already categorized for you.
Cool.
And like Jason had called out,
we do ship five custom
columns into our FOCUS reports
via data exports in the spec.
They call out that, you
know, we can prefix,
any provider can prefix
custom columns with an x_.
These are valuable if you used
some of these CUR 2.0 auto values, right?
If you use cost categories today
or if you're taking a
look for like operations
or usage type, you can pull those values
using these x_ columns.
And then you'll see in our examples
whenever you're joining these data sets
from multiple providers, you're
gonna wanna leave these out
unless you want a bunch
of nulls everywhere.
So, alright.
And then finally, before
we get to the demo,
I wanna take a minute, a
few minutes here to touch,
just talk about the architecture
of like what we're working with today.
So we have this FinOps account, right?
This is where we're gonna
do all of our analysis.
We're not gonna run this in a master payer
because best practices say we
shouldn't run anything there
if we can help it.
And whenever you're trying to work
with your AWS FOCUS data,
we're gonna pull that data across, right?
We're gonna replicate it from the bucket
in your master payer account.
We're gonna move it into this
FinOps account for analysis.
And then you're gonna tie Glue together.
Glue's going to crawl it,
add it to the data catalog
and then we'll use Amazon
Athena to query that data.
And if we were just doing AWS Data today,
this is where this architecture
diagram would stop.
But we want to show multiple clouds.
So depending on, you know, the setup,
you can use something like
the AWS Glue connectors
to reach out to various data sources
and pull other FOCUS data
in, put it in an S3 bucket.
You can use AWS Lambda
to go out and grab things
out of more custom kind
of places if needed.
And some providers may provide options
to push that FOCUS data into an S3 bucket.
So a couple of these examples.
Your use case may differ
depending on which one,
but essentially the common
thing is get the data into S3.
We're gonna use Glue to do
any transformations if needed
and then do the cataloging
so that it's ready to go.
And then finally, to tie it all together,
today we're using a
consolidated view in Athena
that unions all of this data together
to give us one place to query,
and we'll show you what
that view looks like too.
And it doesn't have to be
Athena, you know, I jumped ahead.
You can visualize on top of this too.
So Athena can be a data
source for services
like Amazon Managed Grafana,
for Amazon QuickSight,
for any other BI tools
that can tie into Athena as a data source.
And then once you get
this consolidated view,
you can build whatever graphics
visualizations you need.
And again, it doesn't need to be Athena.
Customers regularly use
Redshift here too, right?
They may do scheduled data loads
or may run Lambda functions
to get things loaded into
Redshift and then use things
like the Redshift Query
Editor v2 to query that data
and then same kind of
deal, any visualization
solutions out there or
services like Grafana
and QuickSight that can use
Redshift as a data source
would work just as fine too.
So, let's see FOCUS in action.
So the first example
we'll have on our demo
is talking through that Athena setup.
Okay, quick spot check.
Can everybody see this?
Is this big enough?
Okay, cool.
Thumbs up. Great.
So we're here in our Athena console.
And just the quick tours,
you know we have our own,
we have a database set up
just for FOCUS samples.
We've pulled in a number
of tables of example data
that we've been able to pull together
from the Azure FinOps toolkit
from the FinOps Foundation
and then our FOCUS reports.
And then we built this
consolidation view down here,
which is what we're gonna
be taking a look at now.
So, this view is an example view
that I've actually borrowed
from the Cloud Intelligence Dashboards.
Hopefully you've heard of them before.
But if you haven't, you know,
it is a solution out here
and they have a FOCUS dashboard available.
And inside of here you can see a lot
of very similar architecture diagrams.
And out here on their
docks they actually have
a published FOCUS consolidation view.
So this is the same way
that they have built their dashboards.
So we've borrowed some
inspiration from them
and then just tuned it kind
of as we needed for the demo.
This line four here is pretty important.
So remember how I called out
the availability zone example
we had shown from the spec.
It's not a mandatory field
so it may not be there.
So there are times where we
use nulls to add these columns,
so the unions work.
So our first one here is just pulling in
our FOCUS v1.0 report.
And you can see we haven't changed much.
We selected just about every column
except for the custom columns.
The one thing to call out
is that our tags field is,
it's a map, map type.
- [Jason] Map stream.
- [Justin] It's a map stream.
And the other examples that
we had were were in JSON
and that would be a
little tough to work with.
So we did cast our tags
to JSON and do a format
just so that things are
nice and consistent today.
Not necessary but is gonna make the demo
a little bit easier.
And then we do a union hall here
where we pulled in the Azure
sample from the FinOps toolkit
and you can see places like
availability zone here,
we've nulled out because
this sample data set
didn't even have that column,
but for the union to work
we needed to have something there.
So it's filled with nulls for now.
And then there are some time places
where we've done some
timestamp formatting,
and that's just again for consistency.
So like casting from ISO 8601
to something a little bit more friendly
for us to work with today.
Alright, and then finally we
did one more union all here
with the FinOps Foundation
sample and this includes
lots of sample data
from multiple providers.
Very similar story just dealing with
some formatting for date times.
For this one, we did have to use coalesce
because some of the
samples had null values
and I don't know if you've
ever tried to multiply
or divide by null, but it
doesn't work out very well.
So we used coalesce here to replace
any of those null values with zeros.
And I mean that's it.
So this view and I can
give you a quick preview
of kind of what we're dealing with here.
Again, this is just a quick
sample of like the first,
you know, first couple
columns that we see.
It's everything that I
guess we would've expected.
Let's go ahead and close outta this.
Now that we've seen how to set this up,
Jason, do you want to walk us through some
of the cost columns and
how to derive savings
and how to think about
like how the different
cost columns work?
- [Jason] Sure.
So as the person who manage cloud costs
and usage data, you
were likely to be asked
the questions like how much have we spent
on invoice last month or how
much money would our usage cost
going to be look like if we do not have
any commitment purchases or how much
will be the amortized cost
if we purchase everything
upfront with the savings plans.
So this can be explained
with full data set
via the full standardized cost today.
Lemme just quickly show you that.
So in the FOCUS data set you
can sum up your build cost,
which is very simple as a build cost.
And this give you the the
cost basis of your invoice.
And for running this
query and you select them
and just hit run, and this will give you
the exact amount that
matches to your invoice.
With FOCUS 1.2 invoice ID columns,
you can actually add in
your invoice ID column
and will show the invoice
that you have paid
for each of the invoice ID.
So this is the help you to
expand the first question,
how much money have you
spent with the invoice
across different providers?
So let me remove that and
answer the second question.
How much would we spend if
we do not have any discounts
or commitment purchases with AWS?
So for this question you
can use the list cost column
which is the equivalent
to the own demand cost
that showed up in the data set.
And for this column will
show your usage costs
without any discounts and
accompaniment purchases.
For correlated column, you
can use a contracted cost
which represent the
cost with the discounts
but without the commitment purchases.
And third, to answer
questions is what would be
my amortized cost going to be look like
if I purchase everything
upfront with the save spend?
So this where Justin will
give a more deep dive here,
but we introduce effective cost column,
which shows your amortized
cost with order discounts
and with order commitment
purchases, reduced rate impact.
So after knowing those three cost columns,
you can do a simple math
by using your list cost
to minus your contract cost to know
how much savings you have
achieved on the discounts.
By using your contracted cost
and to minus your effective costs,
you will know how much
commitment purchase savings
have achieved with your account.
And you can also even do
the percentage of savings
by using your sum of
list cost minus your sum
of effective cost to
get your total savings
and divide by the sum of list cost
and times a hundred to get
the percentage discount.
So in here we have to make a note
that you probably already heard,
I keep emphasizing usage.
In FOCUS data set, the usage
record and the purchase record
are both represented in the nineteens.
In order to understand
different hypothetical scenarios
with discount without a
commitment, you will need
to apply one more filter,
which is called chart category.
And you want to navigate
to the usage record only.
This is because for the
situations like when you have
a savings plan purchase or
upfront with a hundred dollars
and if you have spent
that a hundred dollars
on your cover usages already,
if you don't apply this filter
you will end up getting
your list cost of $200.
So we want to make sure
when you do the analysis
for the usage, make sure apply
this filters into a record.
Okay, let's run the query.
Okay.
- [Justin] So, you may notice
that we've been highlighting
subsections here.
It's a way in Athena to
run like just sections
of your query with a
bunch of the other stuff
that we have further down at my break.
So just highlight everything
that you wanna run there.
- [Jason] Oh yes.
- [Justin] Oh, and line seven.
- [Jason] Yes, contracted cost.
- [Justin] There we go.
- [Jason] Nice catch.
You guys are already FOCUS satisfied.
- [Justin] If we make typos,
please yell them at us. (chuckles)
- [Jason] Okay.
Let's run it.
Okay, let's run it again.
Perfect.
So this shows your usage record as showing
if you do not have commitment
purchases or discounts,
you will be end up paying for
the same usage for $5,130.
And with the discounts
it's going to be less
and your amortized cost going to be $4,300
and your discount saving is 537.
And you will also know your
total savings discount of 16%.
So let me hand over to Justin to do
a more advanced techniques
for the FOCUS queries.
And one thing you need to note
is what queries that we are showing today,
you can also run against
the FOCUS 1.2 data set,
so it's backward compatible.
- [Justin] Alright, so let's
do a super quick demo here
of amortized costs and effective costs.
We had talked a little bit
about how this is possible
with CUR, so I want to give
you just a quick glance
at what that would look like.
So if you're familiar with CUR 2.0,
you'll know that this
may be a little harder
than it would be if you used FOCUS.
So let's see, we want to
grab billing, start date.
Let's grab the, we're doing
a multi-cloud talk today,
so let's grab the billing
entity and the payer.
And we'll add this amortized
cost column, right?
But that's not a column here.
Has anyone ever used
the CUR Query Library,
Cost and Usage Query Library,
hands up if you've ever heard
of our library out there.
So we have this, it's part
of well architected labs,
chockfull of CUR and FOCUS queries
if you're looking to get started
with some of this analysis.
And one of the ones that we have out here
under our library help section
is how to calculate
amortize cost with CUR.
So I've already done the hard work here,
I'm just gonna borrow this so I don't have
to take it all back out
and we'll paste it in here
and then we're gonna FOCUS
in on our sample data set
has all this data from September.
I'm gonna borrow Jason's filter, alright?
And then we're gonna see
what our amortized costs
look like in this payer that
we're running it against.
And I didn't add my table.
I'm not working in the
same space on this one
'cause this is our FOCUS samples,
so I'm gonna grab it out
of a different database.
And you know what, I did this earlier,
I already used the FOCUS column,
and I shouldn't have. (chuckles)
There we go.
Okay.
So you can see here,
to get amortized costs,
we had to copy and paste this
like nine line case statement
where we're evaluating different
parts of the values here
to determine what number we should use.
And you can see for this
payer account we had 2,208.35
as amortized, but we said effective cost
was net amortized, right?
So how do we figure out net amortized?
So we have to pull in those
net fields, those net columns.
And unfortunately for this demo
count there's no discounts,
so a lot of those columns are null.
We're using coalesce here to make sure
that we handle those nulls correctly.
If you've never used coalesce,
we have have another example
in here and I'll show it the next time,
but on the next query.
But we're just gonna copy and
paste this net amortized one
over our amortized cost.
And what it should do is any
place where there's a value
in our related net columns,
it will use those first
else it'll grab our non amortized one.
So this should give us the same values.
Alright, there we go.
So this payer, 2,208.35, great.
So what would this look like
if we were just using FOCUS today?
So the same exact query in FOCUS
is just selecting billing period start,
provider name, billing account ID,
and an effective cost instead
of a nine line case statement.
And we're gonna grab this from
our FOCUS consolidated view
that we set up earlier that should give us
not just this payer account.
- [Jason] I see.
- [Justin] Oh, sum effective cost, yeah.
Gotta sum this up.
Great.
And what we're getting now
is not just our 228.35 here, right,
same value, from this payer,
but now we've pulled in our data
from other providers, other accounts.
Cool.
So that's one of the ways
that you can save some time
not having to build out
your own effective amortized,
net amortized cost field.
So let's talk about the
last example we have here
where we've been tasked to figure out
where workloads may be
running across accounts
and/or providers.
Let's say our boss has come to us
and they've asked us to
track down where like our foo
and far and bar applications are running
and where they cross.
So an example of the data
might look something like this, right?
They show up with a crude
drawing that says show me
where like production
foo is 50% in one account
and 50% in another account
and maybe where things
span different providers as well.
So this is kind of like
what we're working backwards from today.
So the first thing we wanna do
is pull in our cost data, right?
Let's figure out where all of this is.
And this should give us
again very similar view
to what we saw in our effective cost,
one we just did, but we
brought in the account name now
so we can kind of track down
provider's account names
and how much that effective cost was.
So now that we have that,
we need to pull this across
apps and environments, right?
We had production, we had development.
Where are we gonna pull this from?
Anybody have an idea where we'd pull
those kinds of values from?
- [Audience Member] Tags.
- [Justin] Tags, exactly.
So what did the tags look like?
So, let's query our tags column here.
We're gonna use distinct,
so that we can just grab unique values
so we can have an understanding
of like what we're working with.
And great, you can see it's all JSON
thankfully for the JSON
format we did in the view.
But you can see here that in some places
we've used ENV for the environment key.
Some other teams used environment.
Ah, man, those teams, sometimes
they don't follow the tags
exactly as we hope, right?
And then sometimes we have
things like application
and other places we have app
or something else, right?
So we have to be able to like deal
with all of these different values.
So how do we extract some of
these values using Athena?
So I've come up with two different ways
that I think we could work this.
One of them is using JSON extract,
one of 'em is using RegEx.
Does anyone have a preference?
Hands up if you think we should do
the JSON extract one first.
Any idea, any preference?
How about the RegEx?
Anybody interested to see the RegEx one?
We'll start with the JSON one.
So the way JSON extract works,
this is the general pattern you'll follow.
You're gonna call this function.
We're gonna run this over tags.
And then you'd wanna run
this against the path.
So if it's .env, for the key,
that should work just fine.
But like we saw if we run this
it's only gonna give us a subset of them.
So we have like a rough idea on what some
of the environments are
if they use the EMV key.
So in this example we used
another coalesce here,
which again will give us
the first non-null value
in a set of values that you feed it.
You can use, there's
other ways to do this too,
but we're gonna stick with coalesce today
where we can like copy and paste this,
and grab like EMV, we'll
grab like capital EMV,
we'll grab environment
and this should give us
an expanded list of values
here using JSON extract.
Again this is gonna be
dependent on getting everything
into like a nice consistent JSON format.
And we can see here that we have
a couple more values in here. Great.
So, what if we don't have everything
in a nice pretty JSON format?
Well we can still use things like RegEx
to just run it over a string, right?
And JSON is also just a string,
so it works just as fine for that.
Same kind of syntax.
We're gonna call RegEx extract.
We're gonna run this against tags.
And I am not gonna type
a RegEx pattern out
in front of all of you unfortunately.
These are all gonna be shared
in the code examples at the end.
But you know, here are some
examples of different ways
that we can use RegEx extract
to get things like environment.
So we're gonna drop this here
and talk through it real quick.
We're gonna run RegEx against tags.
This is our pattern.
We're looking for any keys that have one
of these four environment patterns.
And then we're gonna be finding anything
that's after the space
colon and double quotes
and we're gonna grab that value.
So that's what this should do for us.
And let's see what that looks like.
See if it looks any different
than our JSON extract.
Okay, so you can see
with our RegEx pattern
we actually captured a
little bit more values.
So a little bit more flexibility here
and I think it's a lot
nicer than having a coalesce
or something with four or five
different values in there.
And the other difference here
is that you can see JSON extract
wraps things in double quotes.
The RegEx, the way that I
wrote it won't, won't wrap it.
So let's, we got environment,
we still need application,
so let's go grab our pattern
here for application.
And you can see I've accounted
for capitalization changes,
I've accounted for some of these teams
using things like project
and the FinOps team
used their own FinOps tag.
So, we've pulled in the
data for all of these
and we'll go ahead and just take
the JSON extract outta here for now.
This should give us a list
of distinct combinations
between environment and application.
So now we can see these
are all the environment
and tag application
combinations in our FOCUS data.
Cool.
So this is how we're gonna
need to pull this data
and to join it with this cost data now
to start figuring out that distribution.
So we figured out cost, we
figured this extraction,
we're gonna join them
now and we're gonna try
to figure out if this foo app
or whichever one of these apps
is split like 50/50 between accounts,
60/40 across providers,
something like that.
So the first thing we're gonna do
is take that first query we typed up
and we wrap it in a with statement.
So that lets us take
these results down here
that we've been seeing the
whole time we're running them
and put them in like
another temporary table,
so we can do more work.
So you can see here, we'll
run this subsection again
just so folks can see we've
added some effective cost
into the mix here.
So this should give us our
provider, our account name,
the environment and app tags
and then this effective cost.
So you can see we have, you know,
a couple of production apps
here costing a couple dollars
in a couple different places.
Cool.
Now that we've wrapped that in a with,
we can go ahead and run queries
against this result set down here.
What this is gonna let us do
is we're gonna use window functions.
I don't know if anyone's
ever used a window function,
but we're going to, for
the sake of calculation,
add each like total cost to the row
for either that environment or that app,
so that we can do more calculations here.
So we're gonna do some effective costs
and we're gonna use over here.
That's gonna give us our window function.
We're gonna partition this
by the RegEx environment tag.
And what this is gonna give us
is show you that column that it adds.
So what this is saying now is
we have this last column here
that shows us the environment cost, right?
So if we scroll over here,
this is saying like our tag
for non-production environments
costs a total of 79.38,
which doesn't seem
particularly interesting
when it's the same
thing as effective cost,
But as we scroll down and
take a look at like prod,
this is our prod environment cost us $314.
That lets us do some calculations
for like how much this row
lines up with its aggregate here.
We're gonna call this total
and the effective cost.
And then what we'll do is
we're actually gonna add
a second calculation
'cause we're not doing this
just for environments, we wanna do this
for apps and environments.
So we're gonna add the
app tag in here as well.
And what this will do is this
will show our environment
and application effective
cost over the whole data set.
Alright, so in this example we now have
some dev stuff up here.
We can see that development
costs us about 1,391 a month
for that particular month.
And that this particular
row, this particular app
and environment tag, so
ActiveBoltMatrix and dev
actually didn't cost
us anything that month,
but there'll be examples
further in the data set here
that where that's not the same.
So these zeros aren't
particularly helpful.
Let's go ahead and filter those out.
So we're gonna take some effective cost
as greater than zero.
And now this should give
us the more interesting set
to poke around in.
Okay, so now we can see, we
have a couple of apps here.
Prod foo has had different costs
here in different accounts.
And the total app in here
cost was like 38 bucks.
And this is where we're
gonna do this math.
We're gonna take like
this row's effective cost
and we're gonna divide it
by this combination cost
to start figuring out where
things are distributed.
So we're gonna wrap everything
in another width here
and we're gonna call
it percentages, right?
So we have our first query that we wrote.
We have this second one where we've added
our window functions.
We filtered out these zeros.
We're also gonna filter
down to production, right?
We don't need, we're just trying
to track down production costs right now.
Okay, and then we're
going to filter out usage
with no app tag because
we saw a couple of those.
So we don't need to see ones
where there's no app tag.
And finally we're gonna
run one final query
over like all of that so that
we only see what we need.
So, we're gonna select
things like provider name,
account name, and then oh, we still need
to calculate the percentage.
So, what we're gonna do here
is we took our sum effective
cost for the row, right,
which is here.
We're gonna divide it by the aggregate,
like this window function
for that function.
And we're going to multiply
by a hundred to get the percentages
and we're gonna select what
we need out of this set.
So this should give us provider name,
the accounts, the
environment app, the cost,
and then these, this like split, right?
And the other piece here is
we only want to see places
where it's not a hundred percent right.
If foo and dev only runs in one place,
that's not interesting.
So we're gonna filter
out places where this app
or the percentage is less than a hundred
and this should give us that report
that we were kind of chasing from here.
What did I miss here?
Oh, I have two froms.
Copy and pasted it wrong.
Okay.
And what this is showing us
is we have two apps here, one called foo,
one called databricks
that run in production
and they're split both across
providers and accounts.
And we can track down that,
you know, prod foo runs,
you know, 2.5% in this AWS account
and it runs about 50/50, 50/46
and these two Microsoft accounts.
And then finally for databricks
we can see, you know,
a similar distribution where it's like 99%
in this one AWS account.
And then there's some workloads out there
that are tagged as prod
databricks running elsewhere.
Cool
- [Jason] As we back to the presentation.
- [Justin] Yeah, so
finally we wanna talk about
visualization real quick.
You know, we poked around in Athena.
Looking at SQL results can be nice
but it's not as pretty
as some of the graphs
that I'm sure a lot of
folks would like to have.
So wanna call out again to the
Cloud Intelligence Dashboards
like that team has done wonderful work.
It is an out of the box
solution visualizing on top
of all the data that we kind
of presented to you guys today.
It has that consolidation view.
They have integrations documented for how
to pull in data from Azure and
Google Cloud, Oracle Cloud.
Today they support FOCUS
1.0 but they have plans
to add 1.2 here soon since
we just recently announced
two weeks, two, three
weeks ago that it was out.
So keep an eye on their change logs.
That's coming soon.
Jason, let's wrap things up.
- [Jason] Sure.
Yeah, thanks, Justin.
The cost allocation and cost attribution
is always a very hard problem
to solve in the cloud.
Cost management especially
involve multi-cloud
or SaaS vendors.
So Justin gave a good demo
to solve that problem with FOCUS data set.
And that data set is also published
in the our current query libraries
that you guys can grab today.
And let's recap what we have learned
since from the question
we asked in the beginning.
Have you seen the FOCUS data set?
We have seen this all together.
Have you analyzed the FOCUS data set?
Which we have done this all together.
And have you joined FOCUS data set?
And in this practice we
joined FOCUS data set
with other providers in Athena.
And what's remaining is
put FOCUS into action.
So after this section, very encourage you
to create a FOCUS export from
the AWS data export platform
and visualize your FOCUS data
and get your hands with the FOCUS.
- [Justin] Yeah, and getting hands on.
Again, hopefully we can make this easy.
We have a whole bunch of resources here
that will link you out
to the code examples
that we had today, the CUR Query Library
where you can get started
either with CUR or FOCUS,
the Cloud Intelligence Dashboards,
a whole nother library of links
if you feel like diving into
cost allocation strategies
on AWS and then both mine and Jason's
socials if you wanna connect.
And of course you know
re:Invent is all week.
There's lots of other sessions
focused on FinOps
practitioners like yourself,
whether it's AI for FinOps, FinOps for AI,
unit cost or cost allocation strategies,
multi-tenant cost allocation strategies,
a whole lot going on.
So check these other sessions out
and come check the cloud ops kiosk.
We do have a kiosk in the AWS
village in the Venetian Expo
where folks like myself and Jason
will be hanging out to
give one-on-one demos.
There's swag and stickers.
Feel free to come and say hey.
And that's it.
Thanks for your time today.
I hope the rest of re:Invent is awesome.
And Jason and I'll hang
out for a couple minutes
if you have questions or
you wanna come up and talk.
I think we have a couple of stickers
that we'd be more than
happy to share with folks.
And please if you could
complete the session survey
in the AWS events app.
We are a data-driven company
and we love all feedback.
So, that's it.
I hope everyone has a great
rest of your week here.